Bueno, continuando con la clase, en este caso vamos a proceder a la instalación de lo que es N8n,
pero en este caso ahora vamos a trabajar como habíamos trabajado anteriormente con lo que es
Google Cloud, ahora vamos a trabajar con Cloud Virtualnel y luego posteriormente en Rock, pero en
este caso lo más interesante sería aplicar en Rock, no sé qué, vamos a en Rock, voy a ver una
nueva pestaña, voy a colocar en rock.com, entramos ahí directamente, esto por sé que
os recordarles que no es necesario hacerlo porque no es parte de lo que es la parte de N8n, pero
sería importante que puedan publicarlo con el N8n para hacer algunas pruebas más que todo con sus
amigos para ver si está en, cómo funciona en producción y demás, ya para esta parte pueden
colocar Get Started for Free, pero ojo no necesito que lo instalen, necesariamente solamente vamos a
descargar algunas partecitas, ya, así que vamos a entrar, en este caso si no tienen una cuenta pueden
registrarse, es sumamente sencillo, se registran con su misma cuenta de email y acceden, ya,
en mi caso yo ya lo tengo, así que voy a loguearme directamente, me logeo y voy a hacer lo siguiente.
Mientras va accediendo vamos a hacer alguna parte con esto y listo, ya, una vez que entro acá,
voy a irme directamente a lo que es, a la piz y aquí nos han ponido que voy a manejar,
vayase directamente a lo que es your out token, ya, en your out token vamos a ingresar
y netamente acá si nos damos cuenta hay una determinada configuración del sistema,
pero yo no necesito tanto eso, lo que yo necesito es que me muestre el out token,
voy a hacer clic acá y ahí se muestra, estos van a copiar y lo van a pegar en una,
en este caso el blog de notas que lo sugiero, guarden eso, a veces lo explica cómo van a manejar,
esa parte, guardenlo o directamente acá, si no quieren mostrar se enclica acá, copy
y lo guarden netamente en un blog de notas o en lo que decen pero si guardenla,
ya para no estar ingresando cada vez. Una vez que lo hacen esa parte, yo voy a tratar de descarar,
ahora si me voy a ir acá, voy a volverme atrás, vamos a irnos atrás y voy a hacer lo siguiente,
voy a volver entre la pura cádida, voy a escribir el nuevo en Glock y vamos a hacer lo siguiente,
se vienen acá en la parte inferior donde dice en este caso, get started for free, hacen clic,
ahora se van acá abajo dice en este caso, instalaciones, pueden hacer clic directamente acá o
pueden descarar mediante su compilador, en este caso yo necesito esto, hacen clic,
los va a detectar por si acaso el tipo de sistema operativo, hacen clic, lo abre el
micro store y lo pueden descargar o hay otra forma, si no les conviene esa forma, van a hacer
la siguiente, van a colocar en Glock, descargar, dole, vienen acá y van a descargar directamente esto,
acá abajo dice van a ser lo mismo pero en este caso esto es la guarden directa y aquí les va a
detectar el tipo de sistema operativo que tengan y cuál es la versión de su máquina, se va a
autodetectar, en mi caso 64 bits, lo voy a descargar, una vez que lo descargan lo van a detener ahí,
si se sirve detener porque no lo necesito, ahora voy a hacer lo siguiente, van a desactivar un
unos momentos, aunque 10 minutitos su cortafuego, en este caso su antivirus y una vez que lo hagan
no lo van a ejecutar porque los va a salir esto y te voy a mostrar, no sé dónde tenía de mí o mi
engroco, yo le guardo por si acaso en esto, ahí está, coloco instaladores y aquí está,
en una carpeta muy aparte lo he guardado y no lo he ejecutado, así les va a salir esto pero
van a descomprimir y eso y lo estoy copiando acá afuera, ahora que van a hacer lo siguiente,
se van a ver otros md, ya se abren otros md y van a copiar la ruta, es decir esta ruta que
donde está guardado el punto x, lo van a copiar, control c, van a escribir lo siguiente,
cd, espacio o en minúsculos, se van a hacer lo cd, espacio, pegan y entera y se van a direccionar
a esa, esa carpeta, ya, ahora para ejecutar esto van a colocar lo siguiente, en groc,
config, at, get on, out, token, out, token y van a pegar acá la, la contraseña o el token que les ha dado
en groc, lo que hemos hecho acá, no? en esta parte, y cuando entran a your token, esta parte lo copian
y lo van a adjuntar acá, espacio y lo adjuntan, ya, listo, ahí voy a, voy a,
quería, voy a borrar esta parte, ok copió otra cosa, listo y voy a copiarme,
vengo acá, copio y lo voy a pegar acá, enter y esto es básicamente, es un acceso de negado pero
porque el mío está con abasto, ya, voy a un cacho desactivar esto, lo voy a desactivar por unos
10 minutitos y listo, ya lo desactivado, ahora si, de nuevo vuelvo a ejecutar, pueden apretar el tecla,
la flechita hacia arriba y lo unimos, los les va a aparecer y ya está, ya, en este caso una vez
que lo tengan, vamos a lo siguiente, pero a mi me está botando algún problemita de un cachito,
ahora si, ya, vamos a abrir otro para no tener problemas, listo, ahora si, ahora se voy a hacer
los mismos, los mismos pasos para que les corriba a ustedes, para que ustedes la corren, el mío
estaba ejecutando anteriormente un proyecto que me está generando problemas, pero igual es la solución,
listo y voy a copiarme eso, ya, ahora si, voy a copiarme,
ahora si, esto tiene que salir así, auto-enclamación,
tal cual les tiene que votar, ya, una vez que lo hagan, todavía no lo estoy generando, no lo estoy diciendo,
ah, crear metunel, cuando lo quiero crear, ahora lo hago, en rock,
HTTP o HTTP, el puerto de N8n, esto pueden trabajar con cualquier tipo de puertos, pueden trabajar con
otros puertos, ya que ustedes conocen de React, de otros frames, pero en este caso voy a copiar
de N8n, de N8n su puerto es el 5678, apretan enter, y esto que vaya corriendo ahí, esto se van a guardar,
en un blog de notas igual, ya, yo voy a abrir un blog de notas muy aparte,
ya, ahí, voy a abrirme esto, ahí lo voy a pegar, mientras tanto mi URL de mi en rock,
vamos a hacer lo siguiente, una vez que hemos realizado esa parte, voy a hacerlo,
siguiente, de mi en cachito, y adónde está mi en rock, mi proyecto, aquí está, ya,
entonces, ahora todo esto, ya lo tenemos, ya trabajamos bastante bien, lo siguiente que voy a hacer,
es generar esto, pero ahora para un Google Sheet, ya, vamos a enviarlo a Google Sheet, pero para esa
parte, vamos a hacer lo siguiente, voy a hacer ahora esto, voy a modificar esto acá, y en este caso
aquí arriba voy a escribir Google Sheets, voy, aquí hay un montón de opciones, ya, yo quiero solamente
que se vaya modificando línea a línea, en mi Google Sheet, ya, les voy a colocar, en este caso,
up and row in sheet, aquí está, up and row in sheet, hago click, me va a aparecer esto, ya,
como me aparece, yo tengo que ingresar en este caso los datos, que me capture y que me envía mi
Google Sheet, pero en este caso, no solamente voy a tener que ingresar esto, ya, voy a tener que
conectarme con una API de Google, para eso, voy a proceder a lo siguiente, voy a hacer ahora esto y
se van a dar cuenta que ya se ha unido acá, ya, ahí pueden modificar y demás, pero esa parte de
conexión con APIs y demás para Google Sheet específicamente, lo vamos a hacer en el siguiente video.